ich kann es nicht erwarten kann meine
lieben freunde wildbret bitte ich habe
mir süßigkeiten aus japan gestellt und
nicht gerade wenig sondern 40
verschiedene wunderlich sagen treffen
die heute einfach mal anfangen kann mit
diesem produkt normen dass hinter der
kamera und war schon mal in japan und
meint damit meinte dass die
schwierigkeit bei diesen japanischen
produkten halte es bzw
die schwierigkeit allgemeine japanischen
supermärkten dass man halt überhaupt
nicht weiß was darauf steht also ich
würde sagen wir fangen wir an mit diesem
komischen produkt schnell das aber noch
keine anrufe irgendwie passt es ist
nochmal das ist halt classic tour ist
das ist platz weg und das ist auch
nochmal plastik das flüssigkeiten
ich glaub das soll schokolade sein aber
er schmeckt einfach extrem beschlüssen
maria weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
ich habe auch wieder keine ahnung was
das hier ist es die iss an
das sieht aus wie menschen ganz komische
konzession ist man probieren
warum denn die sind ja nicht scheiße
also man muss ich gesehen
ich habe dir gerade gegessen und es ist
alles verschwunden meint ohne das etwas
runter gestoppt habe wie die mischung
aus zuckerwatte und popcorn irgendwie
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt das
sieht auf der vorderseite so ein
bisschen aus wie kartoffeln
wieso bratkartoffeln irgendwie so ein
bisschen aber das könne nicht rat hat
auch in seines sind das kartoffel umwelt
diesem grund wird auch ein von denen es
gibt was in deutsche was genau so
schreibt aber ebenfalls nicht ein als
kombi an
kann sein
das nächste produkt ist auch schon
wieder das ist das ist so eine mini
bottle
keine ahnung was da drin ist kennt die
leute die früher richtig komisch und so
genommen haben irgendwie dieses blaue
schlumpf als kaugummi oder dieses pinkl
sind so kleine kügelchen und ich weiß
nicht wie man die ist ich denke jetzt
aber von der hand ab willst du bist du
einfach den chips ich würde dich
produkte gern so ankündigung von gegen
haye produkt heißt so habe das ich habe
bei jedem produkt ist ja drauf geguckt
das einzige was ich hier lesen kannst du
die zahlen
das ablaufdatum 2022 mehr kenne ich
hoffe ich dass ich habe absolut keinen
plan was dass sie auch wieder ist ein
assist gegen die haben wir mit dem
plastik natürlich halt auch der region
deutschland achten diese mittlerweile
schon voll darauf dass chips vielleicht
werden die tüten sind ist einfach alles
noch mal 10 mal mit plastik verpackt es
klebt auf jeden fall extrem kraft steckt
aber ein scheint für nachkommen möchte
noch so
ich würde das nicht so geil das ist so
wie man das liest man sieht schon vorne
drauf legen welche kirchen abgebildet
ich kann euch aber wieder nichts sagen
auch wieder plastikverpackung ist raus
nochmal was ich kann euch wieder nicht
sagen was das ist wohl schmecken wird
wahrscheinlich nach der stadtkirche
fonds abgebildet ist
ich weiß wonach die schmecken aber ich
weiß nicht genau nach was die schmecken
das sind jacobi ist aber hier bin ich
extrem gespannt drauf und zwar sieht es
ein bisschen aus wie so kleine würmer
finde ich weiß du hast schon mal rüber
gegessen
ja also ich schon drin leider in dem
video mit rob damals mal und es hat gar
nicht mal so kacke geschmeckt man sich
das vorstellt dass es war einfach sehr
würzig so ein bisschen die nüsse aber es
ist ein ganz normaler chips ich darf
jetzt nicht das wieder auf amazon
irgendwelche firma verkaufen war schon
recht extrem scheiße wenn man im frei
war zu unterwegs ist und dann hat man
unnormalen hunger im freibad und dann
gibt es da nur so einen komischen snack
startet schmeckt sowie der snack stand
riecht im freibad
damit ihr wisst sofort rede habe ich
überhaupt keinen bock drauf weil es
sieht einfach nur zucker aus den fischen
und folgen aktive tüte weniger
es gibt hier wirklich nichts wo ich
nicht drauf feuerte und ich glaube ich
erstmal berlin das nächste produkt uns
war es ein fisch mit schokolade glaube
ich da kann man ja nicht so viel falsch
machen also er ist wunderbar sagt nur
eines sicher es gibt genau sowas
ähnliches offen deutschland weiß dass
irgendwo was man dann zur schule wird
genommen hat
kingsley toyota die abgase des tacheles
[Musik]
bernd bönte gar nicht warum habt ihr ja
sein von der die erweiterung von
problemen
das tut man wenn man kinder zustand also
bisher kann ich euch auf jeden fall eine
kaufempfehlung aussprechen für diesen
komischen kitsch und für diese komischen
bratkartoffeln homberg job kein problem
das nächste produkt ist wieder irgendwas
mit kirsche vorne drauf und irgendwas
mit keksen also vielleicht geben ich
denke so sind ihre steaks was ist es
muss nicht alles bieten die diabetes
sogar können wir nicht empfehlen komme
jetzt so ein produkt auch dass ich
absolut keinen bock habe und zwar ist
das irgendwie so seetang algen keine
ahnung was da drinnen dass sie daraus
wie frittierte würmer ich passe einfach
ich kann das nicht ernst genug
ich würde immer noch von der anderen
seite ich will deine reaktion kurzfilme
probierst du kannst auch wegducken
irgendwas nur für den geschmack und
ekelhaft kaufen die sowas und ja das
kann nicht wahr sein kann diese was
christen machen wir weiter mit einem
produkt
ach das ist erst vor 13 jahren abgelegt
diesen galt ev meckert obwohl aber
kommen daran oder ich könnte somit die
feier ist obwohl sie von 13 jahren
abgelaufen sind es ist das nächste
produkt wieder mit schokolade zu tun ich
hoffe aber links links nicht dass es
wieder sonne okay ist so kleine bällchen
das fühlt sich so an im multivan auf dem
pulli weist also von material mäßig
bezahlt
ich hätte halt unnormal top wieder auch
ein bisschen dumm gummibärchen tragen
aber wären wir nur so salzige trams
scheiße also hat sie zusammen mit
komischen stick ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
ihnen aber doch keine empfehlung von mir
klar es konnte erst nach er zeit um mein
gott kitkat ok jetzt ist ja auch nicht
weiß jetzt dass dringende special ja das
ist aber nicht mehr zu hause haben die
hosen scheißen hast du das machen wir
wieder weiter mit nächsten produkt kann
früchtetee
dieses match hat geschmeckt japanisch
ist das nächste produkt hat wieder
irgendwas mit sticks und irgendwas mit
dem hof zu tun also es ist anscheinend
denken was presse ich nicht wie zuerst
ist es wieder nur fisch das geht mir
hier auf mich mehr mit verbrechen das
haben wir ja mal wieder irgendetwas
komisches witzigen so einer flasche
trauer kann was das hier ist das
boxenluder sogar drin jetzt die mal
reingucken konnte die band noch mal geil
[Musik]
die ist noch so viel kampf und dann
wagen sagt jetzt schon wege kurzen bevor
ich das essen würde ich mein wissen
lassen
[Musik]